تاخذ
ما في السماوات وما في الارض
يشفع
والنبي يعلمون
ما ولا يحيطون بشيء من علمه الارس
السماوات والارض
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد ان الوجيز في
فقه السنه والكتاب العزيز
ما يباح
يقول المؤلف القبله والمباشره لمن قدر على
ضبط نفسه
[Silence]
இல
المباشره
هذه الكلمه تطلق ويراد بها
وضع البشره على البشره
يعني يلمس
والمباشره
مفاعله
من البشره البشره اللي هو الجلد
فيقال قالوا
مباشره
لان الزوج يضع بشرته على بشره زوجه
وهذا ايضا
لا يقتضي الجماع
وانما يقتضي ما يزيد على القبله ويطلق
المباشره ويراد بهذه الكلمه الجماع
كما في قوله تعالى ولا تباشروهن
وانتم عاكفون في المساجد ومن هذه الايه قد
اجمع العلماء على ابطال
الاعتكاف
بالجماعه
فدلت الايه
على عدم جواز المباشره
في المسجد
والمباشره
بمعنى الجماع
وقت الاعتكاف
كان هذا وهذا المعنى بهذه الكلمه وهذه
الايه الفذه
المباشر
english
‏intimacy that
falls short of intercourse
intimacy that falls
of intercourse
and
also usedران to me intercourse as well
‏me
hus and to kiss and be intimate as
intimacyves
intercourse
then he quotes or a narration which is
مسلم on the auority of
the prophet's
wife قالت كان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقبل
من القبله ويباشر
يعني دون الجماع وهو صائم
وكان املككم
لاربه
الارب بمعنى
حاجه الجماع
عائشه
صلى الله عليه
‏intimate
to that it would not
be intercourse
right
yet he was
most in contr of himself and so we
understand fromish words here that if
this would lead to intimacy
iserm
‏man prop
could
man asked him if could
said yes this is
يقول ومما يباح للصائم ان يصبح جنبا
جنبا من الجنابه يعني وقع الجماع قبل
النوم او وقع الجماع قبل
اذان الفجر ثم دخل وقت الفجر فاصبح اصبح
جنبا
وهذه الجنابه لا تؤثر في صيامه
جناب
اذان فجر
فجر اذان
[Silence]
جناب
فجر
جنابه
تقول عن عائشه وام سلمه رضي الله عنهما ان
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان يدركه الفجر وهو جنب من اهله من اهله
ثم يغتسل ويصوم والحديث في الصحيحين
عائشه ام سلمه واز صلى الله عليه وسلم
the الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جنابه
فجر
[Silence]
الوصال الى السحر الوصال الوصال من الوصل
اي ان يواصل صيامه الى الفجر يعني من
الفجر الى الفجر فلا يجب عليه ان يفطر عند
حلول المغرب بل يجوز له ان يواصل صومه
الى فجر اليوم التالي لكن لا يجوز له ان
يجاوز
من الفجر الى الفجر
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يواصل
الصيام كان يصوم اياما متواصله
وهو صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول تعليلا لذلك
انما يطعمني ربي ويسقيني
وهذا معناه ان قوته الايمانيه
وشدته اليقينيه فانها كانت تقوت جسمه
دون الانسان العادي الذي لا يوحى اليه
فكان يجوز له الوصال في صيامه والصحابه
كانوا يواصلون معه فنهاهم عن ذلك
واجاز لهم
الوصال من الفجر الى الفجر ان ابى احدهم
لكن لا يجوز له ان يواصل
اي
ما ان يجاوز وصاله
ال ان يجاوز وصاله
من ال
الفجر الى الفجر ‏So one of the things
that is permissible notice how the
author
he placed this
point
this point here
in the section regarding
ما يباح
للصائم اي انه يجوز
والا فما هي السنه
وما هو الافضل وما هو الارشد وما هو
الاوفق للقران
ان يفطر
عند
الليل ثم اتم الصيام الى الليل هذا ارشاد
القران وهذا ما امر به النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول
عجلوا الفطر لا يزال الناس بخير ما عجل
الفطر
واخروا السحور الى غير ذلك من الادله
numer
مغرب
24 hours would 24 hours fromج
صلى الله عليه وسلم
upinkan
what seenationen
of
the veil that
‏between this life and life
makes him able to fast for days on end
for other people it is harmful is
harmful to their body
and so when the companions would try to
keep up with him he prohibited them from
doing so
and he allowed them to go from one f to
the next but no more.
قران الله سبحانه وتعالى
قران وكلوا وشربوا حتى يتبين لكم الخيط
الابيض من الخيط الاسود من الفجر ثم اتم
الصيام الى الليل
فجر مغرب
[Silence]
ابي سعيد الخدري صحيح البخاري يقول عن ابي
سعيد الخدري انهم سمع رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم يقول لا تواصلوا
فايكم اراد ان يواصل فليواصل حتى السحر
قالوا فانك تواصل يا رسول الله قال لست
كهيئتكم
اني ابيت
عفوا لست كهيئتكم اني ابيت لي مطعم يطعمني
وساق يسقين
بمعنى ما راه من ايات الله الكبرى
سعيد الخدري
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏do not
f
any youes
only
to time of
saider of but
ஹ
[Silence]
وتعالى
على كل حال
‏a messenger a real messenger
and a fake messenger someone whoaims to
be a prophet and someone who is a
prophet
both of them will have things that are
specific to them that their followers do
not have right
certain rules that apply to them that
don't apply to their followers this
‏alles
have to do with
all of his rules have to do with he can
have you know has to do with women and
has to do with with pleasures
a real messenger all of his rules have
to do with what a higher standard
‏and more regen of his followers these
are the kind of details that one that
conclude
to differenate thatve differentiate
between a true messenger and a false
messenger بهذا القدر اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين